vous l'avez entendu cet implant
contraceptif n'est pas utilisable par
toutes les femmes il vient s'ajouter
dans quelle que soit ta d'autres moyens
contraception des moyens sur lesquels il
y a encore trop peu d'informations comme
l'ont constaté laëtitia le genre et
bernard puissesseau dans un centre de
planning familial à paris elle m'a
expliqué comme la fumure gynécologue
donc ce qui n'a pas fermé mais ce
qu'elle m'a pas expliqué c'est que faire
quand je l'oublié quand je quand j'avais
des problèmes en fait avec cette pilule
justement une pharmacienne qui ne donne
pas suffisamment d'explications sur la
contraception des oublis pilule et la
panique quand elle apprend qu'elle est
enceinte
aujourd'hui mathilde de 19 ans a décidé
d'avorter un acte qu'elle aurait pu
éviter
si elle avait été suffisamment informés
sur la pilule j'étais tout seul pour me
débrouiller donc quand je les ai oubliés
après on se pose des questions comment
on va faire le lendemain est ce qu'on va
en prendre deux est ce qu'on doit
l'arrêter et donc juste de d'une journée
oublier des fois ça peut arriver d'être
consciente
deux femmes sur trois en france
utilisent une méthode contraceptive mais
les chiffres montrent que la
contraception n'est pas encore
suffisamment maîtriser le taux d ivg
s'est stabilisé mais il ne baisse pas
deux cent vingt mille par an soit un
avortement pour quatre naissances
l'exigence ou manque d'information sur
les moyens de contraception y en a pas
suffisamment il faut pérenniser il faut
que ce soit tous les ans ça ne concerne
pas les mêmes populations les jeunes qui
aujourd'hui commence leur sexualité ils
vont là comment ses larmes
non il la campagne contraception l'année
dernière ils ont à peine entendus ils
n'étaient pas concernés donc ils n'ont
pas entendu principal moyen de
contraception pour les femmes la pilule
41% d'entre elles l'utilisent 16% des
femmes ont recours au stérilet 5 au
préservatif une contraception que les
femmes considèrent comme essentiels
elle croit que le nombre de femmes
contre accepté reste identique il est
extrêmement fort dans notre pays
comme dans presque tous les pays riches
dirait et donc il n'y a pas de
diminution de la contraception et d'une
diminution de la prise de contraception
certes les chiffres de la contraception
sont stables mais à un niveau encore
trop faible une nouvelle campagne
nationale permettrait peut-être de faire
sauter les derniers table